(dramatic thud)
- This is the greatest time to be alive,
and you happen to be
living in a great place
for my thesis.
You live in a place where this country
lives its life here,
and the cost for you to enter it,
and do something for yourself
and your family, zero.
(dramatic music)
(shouting)
You got your perspective.
(dramatic music)
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
- Gary Vee.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
(excited shouting)
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
- Thank you.
Thank you, Jakarta.
(upbeat music)
Thank you, thank you.
Sit, sit.
Thank you, I love you back.
(crowd cheering)
I love you back.
How we doing, Jakarta?
(crowd cheers)
I just flew 24 hours.
(audience laughs)
Took a quick shower, plan
on delivering this keynote,
a couple of meetings,
and I'm heading to the airport at 4 p.m.,
so very quick trip,
unfortunately, this time,
but I'm very excited about it.
And there's a whole lot I wanna cover.
So, let me create some context
for some of the people in the room
who don't know as much about me,
and then I'll go into the reason why
I genuinely believe, as
we all sit here today
together, that because of this device
that many of you are holding,
that we are living in the
most opportunistic time
every to put yourself
into a place of happiness,
and happiness comes in all forms.
And I think a lot of business
and entrepreneurship,
but I definitely wanna articulate today
a framework that speaks
to how do you get happy
because of how much
opportunity there actually is.
Let me take a step back.
I was born in the Soviet Union in 1975
a little ways ago.
I came to America when
I was three years old.
It was a very challenging upbringing
in the first couple years.
You know, six family members
in a studio apartment.
We struggled, we had to
learn a new language.
We started from the bottom, no question.
As you can imagine, my parents
are very much my heroes.
My mom stayed home and raised the kids.
My dad worked every day,
many, many, many hours a day.
First, as a stock boy,
putting bottles on the shelf
in a liquor store in New Jersey
for only $2 an hour.
So, very humble beginnings
where the Vaynerchuks come from,
but entrepreneurship was
definitely foundational
in the happiness that
we were able to create
over that period of time.
My dad worked quite a bit.
Eventually, he became the
manager of that liquor store,
and that's when we moved to New Jersey,
outside of New York City.
And that's where I mainly grew up,
and that's where my
entrepreneurial career began.
I always wanted to work.
You know, it came natural to me.
It's what I wanted to do.
When the summer days happened,
and all the kids wanted to play,
I wanted to go wash people's cars.
I wanted to sell lemonade.
I wanted to do business.
It was always in me.
It's what made me happy.
When I was five, six, seven years old,
I convinced all my friends
to stand behind booths
from the lemonade that I made.
And I would make signs,
and try to think about how to market.
Long before the internet, I
cared about one core thing,
which was the attention of the person
that I was trying to reach,
and how I could get them
excited to buy my thing.
Eventually, after lemonade,
I started my first,
kind of, real business.
In America, in the 80's, baseball cards,
sports cards, that people could trade
became very, very big,
and I rode that wave.
I got very involved.
I loved sports, and I loved even more
buying packs of cards, getting good cards,
and reselling them,
and that's really where I learned much.
I mean, to think that sitting here today,
and having so many people clap for you,
on the complete other side of the world,
and so much of that was what I learned
in the malls and conventions in New Jersey
selling these cards, it's remarkable.
I'm very humbled.
I very much appreciate the warm welcome
when I came out here,
and I'm setting up this framework,
because I think, you know,
as I was getting ready
for this conference,
and I looked at so much of the chatter
about the conference,
and, obviously, the
phenomenal Instagram account
of our hosts, and kind of just looked,
the thing that I become fascinated about,
and the thing that I
wanna talk about today
is really two things.
Literally, right before I came out here,
with the organizers, they're
like, talk about the how,
and I asked them, I said, "The how, here,
"or the how here?"
(audience laughs)
What's interesting to
me now that I've been
a little older and had my career,
and I'll go back to it in a minute
to frame it up, but as I'm segwaying,
what's interesting to me is every
wonderful person that
I'm looking at right now,
for them to get what they want, happiness.
Forget about money for
a minute, happiness.
For them to get what they want,
it actually only is one of two things,
here or here.
And here represents doing the work,
knowing what do.
My whole career, as I got
more known on the internet,
I did not want to be a
motivational speaker,
and I spent many years
not talking about this.
I mainly talked about this.
But, after a while, what
started happening was
I started reading enough comments,
'cause I read all my comments,
and I just started realizing so much
of why people can't get
there has to do with this,
that I started talking about it more
over the last four or five years,
but I think they both matter.
You could be the most optimistic,
happy person up here, but if you don't
put in the work, and if you don't know
what work to put in,
it's not gonna happen.
Optimism is very close to delusion.
(audience laughs)
However, I believe that
optimism is the fuel
to practicality, right?
If you don't believe you're
doing it for a reason,
or it's exciting, you're not gonna want
to put in the hours of the work,
and so, that's who I've always been.
I've always been ambitious and happy.
I was very fortunate.
I had a tremendous mother
who loved me very, very
much, so I felt good.
However, she did not create entitlement.
When I lost or I was
doing bad, she told me.
She didn't make a fake environment,
which is a huge factor, and to be honest,
my biggest concern about the
last 20 years of parenting,
too much fake environments,
too much entitlement,
which is why so many people
struggle when they go into the real world
because the real world doesn't care.
The real world is not your mama anymore,
and so, I think about those things.
Fast forward, I was very good
at selling baseball cards.
When you're making three
or $4,000 a weekend
when you're 14 years old, you've got it.
I was good, fine, but then my dad,
eventually, bought a liquor store,
and he dragged me into the liquor store
when I was 14.
I started making two
bucks an hour bagging ice.
This was huge for me.
If I didn't have that transition,
all the money I was making as a young kid,
it came so easy 'cause I
was naturally talented.
I think not having that
struggle of losing all that
because my dad forced
me to work in the store,
and making $20 a day,
that really helped me,
and I learned a lot in that liquor store.
Most of all, what I learned
was to watch people.
Today, after this talk,
I will go to the airport,
and on my flight, I will, literally,
read most of the comments on Twitter,
on Instagram, your DMs, I will read them,
and I'll read them to understand
was there anything I
said in said in this hour
that stood out, that
didn't hit, that did hit.
I learned that watching people,
and more importantly,
understanding people,
and most importantly,
being empathetic to people,
was the best way to build a real business,
to build something meaningful.
The biggest problem,
I'll tell you right now,
one of the biggest reasons
most people in this room,
if they decide to start an
entrepreneurial venture,
a side hustle, whether you try to sell
something in your home
on Facebook Marketplace,
which, oh, by the way,
I'm gonna bring up later.
My biggest believe that the quickest way
for many people here to start is to sell
stuff on Facebook Marketplace.
But I'll talk about that later.
Whether it's that, whether
you're finally ready
to start your podcast on Spotify,
whether you're gonna build
your Instagram profile,
or meme page because
you want brand dollars,
whatever you're up to in this room,
the reality is that if you have to put in
so much work, but so
much of what comes out
of people's mouth, or what they post
is selfish not selfless.
It's what you want.
You want them to buy it.
You want them to like your post.
You want them to follow you.
The biggest reason I have the luxury
of standing here today,
is from the wine business,
to the content I made on
YouTube when it first came out,
to everything I've done over
the last eight to nine years,
in my books, in all my free content,
I've always thought how do
I bring more value to you
than I get in return?
It's very simple.
Karma, or doing the
right thing always works.
The problem is most people are impatient.
The reason most people are impatient,
especially, in cultures
like mine, Eastern European,
in cultures like here,
there's too many people in here
that are trying to get successful too fast
because they wanna prove
it to their parents.
And in that impatience,
is a very important point.
My friends, the number
one thing I fear, period,
is that people live their lives
based on other people's opinions.
The number one thing that I have seen,
as I have gotten older, that has been
very obvious to me,
is that most of the people here today,
do many of the things they do
because of one to five people's
opinions in their lives,
whether their parents, their spouse,
their older sibling, their neighbor.
Living your life predicated
on the judgment of somebody else,
is the great weakness of the human being.
The biggest reason, do you know how many
people are here today
just to get affirmation
from me to go and do something?
(audience laughs)
I mean it.
I mean it, and it's fascinating to me,
and I'm empathetic, I understand,
and I want to talk about it a lot,
because no matter how
I tell you how to leave
500 comments on Instagram posts,
or what time to post your posts,
or why you should start a
Spotify podcast tomorrow,
or how you actually list an
item on Facebook Marketplace,
no matter what I tell you,
if you post the first day,
and the person that you're worried about
has a bad opinion of it,
it's already game over.
And so, I flew all the way here,
24 hours, to put pressure
on what is the most
obvious conversation, which is,
are you prepared to finally
get quiet in your head
and not allow the opinions of others
to dictate your behaviors?
Every person here knows
what they want to do.
If you're here today,
there's something
running through your mind
that you want to do.
There's no reason for you to be here today
unless there's something
running through your mind
that you want to do.
How many people here
are over 40 years old?
Raise your hands, raise them high.
Raise high, don't be scared, raise high.
(audience laughs)
Jesus Christ, this is a young crowd.
(audience cheers and applauds)
For the very small percentage of us here
that are over 40--
- Yeah.
- Thanks, brother.
(audience laughs)
There's like eight of us, bro.
For, like, the 11 of us,
look, here's, this is a lot of fun,
for the 11 of us, we
lived life before this.
We were grown.
We were grownups already
before the internet came.
I was 18 years old.
I'd lived my life, at least,
the childhood part of my
life, without the internet.
The biggest thing that excites me,
especially in a mature
internet market like here,
WhatsApp, and Facebook, and Instagram,
and YouTube, and Spotify, like,
there's so much opportunity,
and you don't even have
to leave your home.
There's no building your life, you know,
after hours, when I was growing up.
When you had a job, and you
had to take care of something,
you didn't then start another
job because it was late,
but, now, this allows it.
The biggest thing that I wanna get across
in this little moment of this speech,
is everybody in here is
taking this for granted.
Your grandparents, your
great-grandparents,
your great-great grandparents,
they didn't have this.
If you aren't succeeding, or attacking
your success with this in your hand,
then what are you doing?
Every single person
here has the opportunity
to create a profile
and a presence online
whether it's yourself, or your business,
or your idea, and the
cost is (clicks) zero.
I love when people get made when Facebook
or Instagram's organic reach goes down.
I keep reminding them it's free.
(audience laughs)
How many people here are on Instagram?
Raise your hand.
Jesus.
(audience laughs)
Over the next year or two,
Instagram's reach is gonna go down
because more ads are going to go in.
So, as you can imagine, I'm so passionate
to get you to post three
or four times a day,
not once a day, yet, everybody
overthinks their posts,
so much, 'cause there's so scared not get
as many likes as they did last time.
(audience laughs)
It's true, it's 100% true.
The amount of people here
who want to post something,
but retake it 53 times.
(audience laughs)
Or change the filter, or
things of that nature,
or, my favorite move, you post it,
but in the first 83 seconds,
you don't get enough
likes, and you remove it.
(audience laughs)
It's a fascinating thing for me to watch
because what it speaks
to is, in my opinion,
people being confused about the game.
I view the game macro.
I watch most people play micro.
You're not in the business of
getting likes on Instagram.
Yet, you're pandering
to the machine of that.
You're in the business
of creating awareness
for whatever you want.
You want people to know
what you want them to know,
whatever that may be,
business, raise money for a charity,
sell something, become a personal brand.
You know, whatever it might be.
(audience laughs)
Whatever it might be,
that's what you want,
yet, people get so caught
up in the semantics.
Listen, what I can tell
you from my career,
is this repeats over,
and over, and over again.
In 2006, I started one of the
first YouTube shows, period.
It was the longest show on
YouTube when I launched it.
YouTube wasn't even a year old.
I sat in front of a camera,
and I drank wine for 30 minutes,
and a lot of people watched it.
(audience laughs)
A year later, Twitter came out,
and I was one of the first
people to move on that.
I invested because I got
smarter at that point,
but I also was one of the first people
to amass a million
followers on that platform.
Before I did YouTube and Twitter,
a year or two earlier, in America
and many other parts of the world,
MySpace had won and dominated,
and there were people
that won on that platform.
If you pay attention to
what happened on MySpace,
if you pay attention to
what happened on YouTube,
what happened on Twitter,
and then Facebook, and then Vine,
and on, and on, and on,
it's all the same game.
In the beginning, if you move quickly,
you can get more attention.
Most people get frustrated
that they aren't first,
and they don't go all in
'cause they think they missed it.
However, winning on these platforms
is a game of being better, not first.
Being better comes in two ways.
This is where it gets very
important, my friends.
Being better on putting out content
only comes out in two ways.
Either, entertainment, right?
Or information.
If you are putting out
content on these websites,
and trying to grow,
and you want to succeed
and build an audience,
you either do information,
you know what you're talking about,
whether it's painting nails, business,
wine, sneakers, hair care.
I don't care what it is.
You either know or you entertain.
Entertainment comes in a lot of ways.
This is playing out on Instagram.
Entertainment comes in being funny.
Entertainment comes in being musical.
Entertainment and escapism
comes in being attractive,
being a model.
It all plays, if you're
lucky enough to have both,
it gets really crazy.
But if you do not do one
or the other, you lose.
If you go look at your
Instagram account right now,
and look at the last 10 posts,
my question to you is very simple,
did you post those posts for your audience
so they could be entertained or informed,
or did you post it for yourself,
for your own self-esteem, or insecurities?
(audience laughs)
Let me save you time.
You posted it for yourself.
(audience laughs)
The biggest take away that
you could have from here,
in my opinion, is a couple of things.
Number one, you are very fortunate
to live in a country with
disproportionate advances
on these platforms.
When I look at the data
of how much attention
is on this device, and those six platforms
in this country, and the
size of this country,
it is staggering.
This is one of the best places
in the world to produce
content for YouTube,
Spotify, Facebook, Instagram, Twitter.
It's one of the best places in the world.
(audience applauds)
See, you did it again.
You clapped for yourself.
(audience laughs)
Oh, actually fun fact.
Actually, back to this amazing place,
and the internet, and apps.
I don't know if a lot of you know this,
but I was one of the first
five investors in Path,
which was a huge app here
for a long period of time
before it shut down a year ago.
So because I was an
early investor in Path,
and because this became
the biggest market for Path
four or five years ago,
I spent a lot of time paying
attention to this market
from far away, and what
I can tell you is this,
the beauty of the people that live here,
and it's funny, there's
so much amazingness.
You know, in the world that I see,
how many people here consume my content?
Raise your hands.
Thank you, so, thank you.
So, if you do, you have
a good sense of me.
You can imagine why I
love Indonesia so much.
All the love, and optimism,
and warmth plays out here,
but the biggest thing I'm passionate about
is getting people to be less insecure,
and care less about what people think,
especially their parents,
plays out here, too.
And so, for me, it's a really
interesting market to look at
with trends and how people do things,
and what they respond to,
and who they follow, and why,
and so what I can tell you is
if you are capable, if you are capable
to be strong enough, internally,
to start posting on these platforms,
more truth, more your truth,
you, you're truth, you will
see a remarkable return
on that investment in this market.
Now, let's talk about content
because no matter what
you're doing in this room,
you're gonna have to produce it
to achieve what you want.
The problem is there's a lot
of ways to produce content.
One of the biggest issues that
I'm excited to address here
is a world where Instagram
does extremely well,
or YouTube, people think
pictures and videos
are the only way to go.
I'm here to tell you
that two of the places
that I'm most excited about
are the written word and audio.
(audience member cheers)
If you are not comfortable
taking tons of pictures
and videos, you immediately have to make
a decision here today.
Are you a good writer?
And if you are, I have a
lot of good news for you.
I'll go to that in a minute.
Or, two, if you like to talk,
however you're uncomfortable with video,
I couldn't be, back to your clapping,
more passionate about the last six months,
in Indonesia, the
consumption of podcasting
in this country is exploding.
(audience applauds)
The unbelievable ease to produce a podcast
and distribute it in 2019 is remarkable.
There's an app I've been
talking about a long time.
It just got bought by
Spotify, called Anchor.
It's called Anchor.
You can download it on your phone.
You literally record on your phone.
You press two more buttons,
and it puts it all over
to the different podcasts.
No friction.
You could be doing it right now.
So, the excuse of I
don't know how to do it,
or how do I produce it,
or do I have to go to the radio station?
And how do I?
Nothing, cost of entry, zero.
Friction, zero.
Literally, all you have to do is Google,
how do I use Anchor?
Or download it.
I highly recommend if
you have something to say
about some category, I highly recommend
getting very serious about podcasts.
'Cause I believe that audio,
over the next decade, is going to be
one of the biggest ways we consume
because we don't like wasting time.
Humans love efficiency.
And audio saves time.
Audio's exploding, and
will continue to explode,
and I highly recommend
you look at it seriously.
Another thing that's interesting to me
is actually a little tidbit
I don't share very often,
but I always say, "Watch
what I do, not what I say."
When I looked at the
hashtags or the comments
for this conference, I looked
at a bunch of accounts.
The number one mistake I believe people
are doing on Instagram right now,
is not leaving enough written copy.
If you look at my posts,
when I post a picture
or video on Instagram,
I write a lot of copy.
I don't do that for my health.
I don't like wasting three minutes.
I do it 'cause it matters.
So, I know a lot of you are
trying to build your Instagram.
One of the best tidbits I can give you
is please start adding, two, three,
four, five, six, seven
sentences to your posts.
Add context, add clarity,
add a little story.
You will see substantial returns.
Speaking of written, how many
people here are on LinkedIn?
Raise you hands.
Quite a few.
If you're paying attention to
me, you might have noticed.
Literally, I've talked about LinkedIn more
in the last four months, than I have
in the last seven years.
LinkedIn's content,
business, its business,
and even if you're a fitness influencer,
there's a way to do business content.
Write an article, six things a traveling
business woman and man can do
when they're in a hotel room.
So you can always make your content fit.
LinkedIn organic reach on
content is very high, very high.
I highly recommend everybody here
get serious about your LinkedIn.
I know a lot of you haven't signed in
in three years, four years.
The LinkedIn many of us grew up with
was just to get a job.
It's now about business content,
and I believe whether,
again, you sell rugs,
or sneakers, or wine, there's a way
to write content for LinkedIn.
Remember, the mindset of the
person on LinkedIn is business.
So you have to consider that.
It's different than Instagram, right?
LinkedIn is your office.
Instagram is the club, you know?
(audience laughs)
So you have to act differently.
You have to act differently,
but I'm telling you right now,
LinkedIn and Spotify podcasts,
for a lot of this room,
that hasn't been making,
is a very big opportunity.
Posting three, four
times a day on Instagram
is a very big opportunity.
All this content that I want you to write
Content is how you will
make your happiness happen.
Putting out content is how
you will make your happiness,
whether that's build a big business,
whether that's get a dream
job, a collaboration.
Content, talking, content
is how you'll make
your happiness happen.
The problem is I need you
to look inside yourself
and tell me why you're not doing it.
To me, what I've learned in
the last five or seven years,
I can sit here for a half an hour
and give you every detail.
I can tell you right now that if you go
into your Explore page on Instagram
and click on every one of those videos,
and then go leave a comment on that post,
a thoughtful comment.
Watch the video or picture,
not just hey or an emoji.
Look at it, and spend two minutes,
and leave a comment,
that if you do that 30, 40, 60,
a hundred times a day, if you're hungry,
if you're ambitious,
if you want something,
if you do that, I know that will work.
It will work, you will grow.
You will get more attention.
You will get more attention
to your business, to yourself.
My question is why won't you do it?
Will you not leave a comment
'cause you're nervous
to leave a comment on
somebody who's famous's page?
Will you not leave a comment
because you think somebody's
going to judge your comment?
Will you not leave a comment
because you don't wanna spend
an hour leaving comments?
Why?
For me, everything is
about reverse engineering.
What do you want to happen?
Like, what, what do you want to happen?
And then understanding, in 2019,
that written words, audio, and video
on seven platforms can get
you there is remarkable.
It's just remarkable.
It's so crazy to me.
I'm sitting here
listening, as I'm talking,
and I'm, literally, blown
away that I believe it.
I mean it.
I'm shocked that we're now living
at a time where the internet is at scale.
The apps that dominate
the culture are free.
You could, literally,
walk out of here right now
and start the process of
changing the course of your life,
if you want, and,
literally, the only thing
left now, because the excuse
of money and time is over.
That's amazing.
The fact that money and
time have been subsidized
by the internet because you can lay in bed
and do it at 11 p.m., if you want,
and the cost is zero.
You don't have to buy a
store, and open it, like zero.
It eliminates all your excuses,
and now the question is why not?
Why are you not?
And so, I'm very passionate of getting
this room, today, to start thinking about
what they want to be doing,
and how, and where, and why.
I'm breaking it down into audio,
written word, videos, and pictures.
You know what the five
or six platforms are.
Now, it just becomes the
match to get it started,
and more importantly,
and the biggest thing
that I fear, will the
group have enough patience
to see the results?
I was on Twitter from 2007 to 2011,
and I replied to every single person
that twitted at me, and in the beginning,
'cause nobody knew who I was,
I went to Twitter search, and I searched
the word wine, and other wine terms,
found people talking about it,
jumped into the conversation,
and left good information.
I did that for seven to eight
hours a day, for four years,
before anybody gave a
fuck about who I was.
(audience laughs and applauds)
Let me say that slowly one more time.
For seven to eight hours a day,
for four years, I would
go to Twitter search,
search wine terms, jump into them,
and give information for four years
before anybody gave a fuck who I was.
Now, I get DMs from people saying,
in three weeks I'll get
a DM from somebody here
saying, Gary, saw you in Jakarta.
It was awesome.
I started doing stuff.
I'm not getting any traction.
I reply, that's nice Mario.
You've been doing it
for three fucking weeks.
(audience laughs)
Let me take a real step back.
If you're sitting in this chair,
and you wanna do something
that makes you happy,
and makes you money, let's just say that.
I have no idea what people
want in here, but fine.
How many people happy money?
Raise your hands if you want happy,
raise it, don't be scared.
Great.
Let me ask you a question.
If you have the audacity
to be happy and have money,
which, by the way, the amount of people
who have lots of money and
are very happy is very small.
It just is.
(laughing)
If you wanna be happy and have money
don't you think it should take a long time
and it should be hard?
Right?
That, to me, has been the
most interesting thing.
In this world that everything is so fast,
and this world where one or two people
look like Mark Zuckerberg, or trav-lik,
where you can point to one or two people.
I don't know if you heard,
there's 7.7 billion of us,
but, because you can
point to one or two people
that got it fast and a lot,
all of a sudden,
everybody thinks it should
be fast and a lot.
At 34 years old, after
working for 12 years,
helping build my family business,
I left my family business,
and I had no money.
34, no money.
How many people here younger than 34?
Raise your hands.
Dee-rahk where are you?
(audience laughs)
Hold on, keep 'em up.
Dee-rahk, where are you?
Yo, right here, come here.
Look at this.
Put the lights on.
Hands up.
Look at this.
Every hand here, stand up, actually,
if you raised your hand, stand up.
(speaking in foreign language)
Every person here standing
is under 34 years old.
When I left Wine Library, day-to-day
at 34 years old, I had nothing.
When I started VaynerMedia,
we started it in Buddy
Media's conference room
'cause I didn't have
dollars to spend on rent.
Imagine how early I think
you are in your life.
You can sit, thank you.
(audience applauds)
If you can keep the lights on, I like it.
Thank you.
(audience laughs)
Beautiful, thank you.
My friends, it's early.
It's early for 100% of
the people in the room.
It's ridiculously early
for 95% of this room.
This internet thing, it's big.
It's real big.
We haven't even started.
Please, understand how lucky.
That's the only word I have for it.
How lucky you are that you
get to live during this era,
right now, anything that
comes out of your mouth
that's complaining, makes your grandfather
wanna punch you in the fucking face.
(audience laughs)
You understand?
Do you understand how
much better you have it
than every generation before you?
This is such a ridiculously special time,
and, literally, the far
majority of this room
is not going to take advantage of it
because of the insecurity of worrying
about somebody who they don't even know
leaving a comment that they're ugly.
(audience laughs)
Are you, literally, not
going to take advantage
of the actual ability to
be happy and successful
because somebody comes on your account
and says you're stupid?
But this is what's playing out.
This is what's happening.
I mean, look at different cultures.
On the way here, to you know that one of
the biggest things that was DMed here
is that there's a lot of people
coming here by themselves,
and they wanted advice,
how to say hello to somebody
that they didn't know?
What are you scared of,
they're gonna bite you?
(audience laughs)
We're living in a very fascinating time,
a very fascinating time.
It reminds me of when
new countries are born
and people buy up real estate.
The attention, the attention
of this room is real estate.
You're trying to get it.
Everybody's living on these things.
It's going to happen more, not less.
You can judge it, that's fine,
but that's what's gonna happen.
And so, if you are not producing words,
and videos, and sounds,
for these seven platforms,
you almost don't exist.
Now what you say, though,
matters very much.
And let me give you a
couple of advice points
from somebody who's really won.
The number one thing you have to always do
is talk about what you know.
I watch people try to talk about stuff
they don't know every single day
because it's hot, whether it's cannabis,
or sports betting, or block chain,
or social media, people
start talking about
things they don't know anything about
'cause they're trying to grab.
They think they're
going to get fast score.
Everybody wants a fast score.
Do you know how many
people have emailed me
crying about buying Bitcoin
at 10 thousand a coin?
'Cause it was going to be
100 thousand in a year.
(audience laughs)
People are looking for fast scores.
You know how many people here
spent $800 on a course 'cause
it was gonna happen fast?
Fast is bad.
Fast, if you have talent and
the right intent is amazing.
Fast, if you want cash
immediately. (clicks)
So, please, please, please understand
the world you're living in.
Take it into context.
Understand how remarkable this era is.
Next, this is the most important word.
You have to deploy self-awareness.
My friends, self-awareness
is the most important word.
If you don't know who you
are, you have no shot.
But do not be embarrassed of who you are.
When I knew that I was an
entrepreneur in the 80's,
I got Ds and Fs in school,
and that was not acceptable
in the 80's and 90's, in America.
If you were a bad student, in America,
in the 80's and 90's, you were a loser.
My friend's parents, looked at me,
looked at me as I was a loser.
But I knew who I was.
I was self-aware.
I knew that I was an entrepreneur.
I wanted to go and sell
things on the weekend.
I wanted to study the prices
of wine and baseball cards
instead of studying for school.
I knew who I was.
Playing video games seemed like
a waste of time 20 years ago.
Now there are people who make $50 million
a year playing video games.
If there's something you know,
and you like, and you're passionate about,
but it's not cool right now or important,
do not deviate away from your thing,
triple down on your thing.
The other thing is, be self-aware.
How many people here are an
entrepreneur or want to be?
Raise your hands.
I'm just curious.
It's a lot of hands.
The reality is, most of
you can't be successful.
I mean that.
I'm not saying to to razz.
It's rare to be a successful entrepreneur.
It's hard.
It's a real talent.
We don't think it's a talent now
'cause it's so easy to say you're one.
One of the most important things
about being self-aware, is knowing
do you have the stomach
to be an entrepreneur?
Putting entrepreneur in your
Instagram account, easy.
Living the life of an entrepreneur,
where nobody else is on
the line, except you,
hard, lonely, scary, difficult.
If you do it 'cause it's cool,
or you think it's right,
or you're not self-aware,
it leads to depression and loss of money.
If you deploy self-awareness and realize
you're a number two, a number three,
a number four, you find an
entrepreneur, and you win.
Self-awareness, you have
to understand who you are.
Without it, you're massively
vulnerable in society,
and the fact that we now live in a world
where you're more than welcome
to be what you are, so much more.
Maybe not in your family
because your parents
want you to be a doctor, and a lawyer,
and an engineer, but in the world, yes.
And so, I highly recommend self-awareness.
It is easily, in my opinion,
I believe that self-awareness,
and the ability
to actually give without expectation,
are the two bricks of happiness.
And it's been a big factor for me,
which has allowed me to go fast.
When you're stable, you can go fast
because you're not worried about judgment.
I've been able to do a lot of things
'cause I'm not scared to lose
because if I lose, it's my loss.
If I lose money or time,
it's my loss, not yours.
I don't care what you say in the comments.
That lack of fear is what gives
an entrepreneur an advantage.
That lack of fear is what lets somebody
live life in happiness.
We have to start having
more important conversations
of the operating system of your life.
There are people here that work more
on upgrading their phones
than upgrading their minds.
I mean it, I mean it.
I am desperate.
Listen, to come here, all this way,
to talk about tactics, is a waste of time.
To come all this way, and
have one person in here
gain actual courage to do something,
is super worth it.
And, for me, it's a very simple game.
Let me give a very big secret
to all the kids here who
are living their lives
for their parents, or based
on their parents' judgment.
There's a very big secret
that parents never tell you.
If you go the other direction
of where they want you to go,
and you become really successful,
they are really proud,
and may pretend they never
pushed you in the other direction.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
The number one thing I fear,
and the number one thing I learned,
and this is very interesting to me.
I'm gonna tell you a
story I don't tell a lot.
When I was a little kid,
in Edison, New Jersey,
when grandparents came over,
I would go play with the
grandparents, a lot, a lot.
Maybe it was because I lost three
of my four grandparents, as a kid,
but, even as I get goosebumps
right here on stage,
it's because I think I've always been
filled with a lot of wisdom and old soul.
It's just DNA.
It's nothing I did.
It's just been in me.
But I was always gravitating
towards old people,
my whole life.
I mean really old.
You know, I'm seven, eight years old,
I see an 80-year-old, I run over,
sit next to them and talk.
My whole life, I loved it, my whole life.
And the number one thing I learned
in the first 20 years of my life,
spending more time with
old people than most kids
is the biggest thing I fear is regret.
Regret is scary.
Resentment is very scary.
The biggest reason I push kids
to do what they want, versus
what their parents want,
is because I'd rather
them and their parents
have five, or six, or seven
years of bad, than 80.
Because it gets very ugly when you're 60
and their 80, and you lived your life
based on what they wanted,
and now you resent them.
It gets real ugly real fast.
I would rather you have the pain
for the next five or
six years of fighting,
and then have one of two things happen,
which I think both are amazing.
Number one, you were right.
You were right, and you are
an amazing fashion designer,
not an engineer, and you
built a real company,
and you're parents are
gonna be very, very proud.
Or, you were wrong.
You suck at fashion design.
Nobody liked it, but
at least, for yourself,
you never have to live
the rest of your life
asking yourself what if.
You win both ways.
You live in a culture, I know, I watch.
You live in a culture with
a lot of expectations.
You live in a culture where parents
treat their kids as a property
that indicates who they are.
So does most of the world.
This is not a Southeast Asia thing.
This is not an Indonesia thing.
This is a world thing.
Parents are insecure, too.
And they like their
kids closing their gap.
We have to start talking about this.
Because now that it costs zero
to start a Spotify podcast,
now that you can do that at 9 p.m.,
now there's nothing left.
In 1974, not having money
and time was an excuse.
In 2019, it is not,
and so the only thing left, is this,
not this, this.
And so, I come here today begging,
not pleading, not asking,
begging you to look yourself
in the mirror tonight,
and ask yourself if you're happy.
And people always say, "I
don't know what my passion is.
"I don't know what I would do."
Yes, you do, you do.
You just don't think it would work.
You think it's too small.
You think it's too silly.
You think people would judge you.
You know, you're just scared to say it.
You know exactly what you would do
if you could do it every
minute of your life.
You may not, right now,
as I'm saying this,
you're like, no, I don't.
Gary, I don't.
It's 'cause you haven't even
allowed yourself to look.
This is the time
to build businesses,
and profiles, and content
around what you enjoy.
This is the time, this is the time,
and waiting one more day
makes no sense to me.
So, whether you use the momentum
of the energy that we created today
or something else, please
don't get older and regret.
Please don't watch this exact video
on whatever YouTube is in 35 years.
You wanna hear something weird?
Everybody in here right now,
is actually watching this,
right now, in 35 years.
Everybody here, right
now, is actually gonna
watch this exact talk, on video,
on the internet, in 35 years.
And I'm gonna ask you,
did you fuck up, or no?
(audience laughs)
I mean it, I mean it
because what I'm interested in is
did you understand what
I was saying here today,
and do something about it,
or do you do what so many people do?
Do you know what I watch everyday?
I watch people see a video
clip of mine on Instagram,
or YouTube, or Facebook, or what have you,
leave a comment that that was the clip
that changed their life, right?
It feels very nice.
Oh, my god, this just changed my life.
I'm going to do it.
But I'm weird.
You know what I do?
I follow them.
(audience laughs)
And sometimes, especially
on trips like this
when I'm in the air for 24 fucking hours,
I will go and look and see six months,
nine months, a year later, if
they did anything about it,
and 99% don't.
(audience laughs)
There's a lot of people
in this room right now
that said, this is it, I'm going to.
(laughs)
(audience laughs)
I see you.
And then in 2 1/2 weeks,
all the energy's going to be gone.
(audience murmurs)
And I spend every day thinking about that.
(audience laughs)
One of the biggest reasons
I produce so much content,
as I use to speak a lot,
but then there wasn't as much content.
So I thought, okay, maybe if I put out
content eight times a day,
it can get them going.
I've come to learn,
and I very much believe this,
I was gifted and parented very well.
That allowed me to actually not care
about other people's opinions.
I respect them.
I never think I'm always right.
This is not about thinking you're right.
This is not about me being
delusional, or audacious.
This is me understanding
that, if you judge me,
you don't have all the context.
You don't know me.
So how do I know you?
I don't.
Even the person closest to you,
a spouse, a parent, they don't know.
Nobody knows.
So, why would you take
somebody else's opinion
over your own?
Please, my friends, don't live a life
that gets you to 80, 90, 100 years old,
where you're sitting there saying,
I wish I did, I wonder if I did.
Nobody at 90 years old,
go find your oldest relative,
and go take them out to lunch,
and ask them, just like this.
Talk to me about life.
They will not talk to
you about what they did.
They will talk to you
about what they did not do.
They will talk to you about
what they wished they did.
Don't wish.
They had an excuse, your grandparents,
your great-grandparents.
It wasn't practical.
You couldn't do what we can do.
This didn't exist, oh.
(audience laughs)
This did not exist.
Please, take advantage.
Please, take advantage of this existing.
This is the greatest era to be alive.
It is, there's plenty
going on in the world.
Plenty going on in my country.
Plenty going on in the world.
But when you look at the macro data,
this is the greatest time to be alive,
and you happen to be living
in a great place for my thesis.
You live in a place where this country
lives its life here.
And the cost for you to enter it
and do something for
yourself and your family?
Zero, zero dollars.
I do not want to hear
that you don't have money.
I don't wanna hear that somebody else
is further along because.
Nobody else's life matters.
This is an inside game, inside.
Start making content.
Start talking to the world about what you,
either, like or you know.
Do it every day.
Close your eyes for five years.
Not how are you doing in five days.
Not how you're doing in
five months, five years.
I come back here in five years,
or I see you in an airport in five years,
and you say, every day I
made five pieces of content,
and I went nowhere, I
would say two things.
Number one, I'm proud of
you, that was a long time.
(audience laughs)
Number two, you clearly
suck because if you're
putting out thing for five years,
and nobody gives a shit, your stuff sucks.
(audience laughs)
Please, please, I hope,
Jakarta, you heard me today.
Everything on the platforms, you know.
You know which ones people use.
You use them, your friends use them.
You don't need that information.
What you do do need to
do is take a step back
and don't think that videos and pictures
are the only way.
I do think audio and written word,
for a lot of people here, matters.
By the amount of hands that went up
for entrepreneurship, I
think a lot of people here
have to look themselves in the mirror,
and ask who they really are.
Are you self-aware about your skills?
But leaning into what you're interested in
and producing content, has
never been more practical,
and I implore you.
I implore you to take advantage
of this very special time
because you have one life.
You might as well live it, thank you.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
Q and A?
I know we're gonna do some Q and A.
- [Man] Ladies and gentlemen,
please give it up for Gary Vee.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
- Gary Vee?
- Yes, sir?
- Thank you for being here.
- Thanks for having me.
- It was really good.
- Thank you.
- We have a Q and A after this.
So, if you can just sit down
to my right.
- Okay.
- We have a few questions
from the audience
member that we have chosen
from our social media.
They are here with us today.
- I've heard of social media.
Yes.
- So, without further ado,
our first question comes from Alexander.
Is Alexander here?
- Hello, hello.
- What up, Alexander?
- I'm good.
- Good.
- Thank you so much for--
- Let's clap it up for Alexander.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you for the plans that you give me
that's make me wakes up,
and I own a small branding agency.
- You have one?
- Yes.
- [Gary] Okay.
- That help fashion brand designer, local,
to get them the better
logo, better brand identity,
and better campaign.
- Understood.
- What I want to ask is should I learn
all the skill, I mean, be a generalist,
So I can see the
- Yes.
Bigger picture or,
- Or I focus on one skill.
- No.
- That make me specialist or expert?
- No, I'll tell you why.
You're too young, and how will you know?
If you decide, right now, to be an expert
just on Instagram organic
creative, let's say that.
How do you know that you're not the most
talented strategist around Spotify
growth of podcasts?
Until you become a generalist,
do you even know which thing
to become an expert in?
- That left him speechless.
- I see.
(Alexander's speech drowned
out by audience laughter)
- But you understand, Alexander?
- [Alexander] Yes, yes,
I got it, I got it.
- Like, like, you're, fucking, a kid.
(audience laughs)
No, that's good.
You don't know, yet, what you're best at.
Like, why are you picking your expertise,
if you haven't seen everything else.
It's like food.
I love when people are like, Gary,
I like eating exotic food.
So, sometimes I'm in a meeting,
and I'll order oysters, or sea urchin,
or whatever I order, and I go,
and my dinner person will be like,
I don't like oysters.
I'm like, well, have
you ever had an oyster?
No.
(audience laughs)
And that's how I think about this.
You need to understand ads,
and media and ads, and creative,
and Spotify, and Instagram, and LinkedIn.
You have to taste everything.
You may think Instagram's delicious,
until you actually taste LinkedIn.
You need to be a generalist first,
then you can tell me
what you're an expert in.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
- Should we go to the next question?
- Please.
- All right.
The next question comes
from Meh-dee As-tah-reen-ah.
Is she here?
There she is.
- Okay, awesome.
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- I'm fine, thanks for the opportunity.
(audience laughs)
I'm Meh-dee.
Okay, so me and my
spouse have a photography
and videography agency.
And both of our parents
don't do business at all.
They work from eight to five,
so they, kind of,
not believing in us.
- Right.
- And then, after two or three years,
we started to think that
we may need an investor.
- After two or three years, you what?
- We might an need an investor.
- [Gary] An investor, okay.
- So, I want to know, from you,
because you have already
invest in many things,
as an investor, what is
the most crucial thing
you see in the business
you're going to invest in?
What makes you invest in them?
- So, for me, when I look at investing,
there's only two things I care about.
One, do I generally believe
in the idea or the concept,
and, then, two, and more importantly,
do I believe in her or him,
and their capable to drive it.
I've lost a lot of money, as an investor,
in the last 10 years, 15 years,
when I loved the idea so much,
and I could figure out
what I would do with it,
but the person running the
business wasn't capable.
And I learned from that.
So, now, it's 51%, 51% you,
49% the idea or the concept.
That's what I look for,
but I think more importantly,
because I want you to be successful,
what startups here need to do,
or businesses here, you
need to find investors
who are most likely to invest in you.
I see so many people wanting to get money
from the cool VC or a bank,
and they're never gonna get it.
You need to find the investor
that's gonna invest in you,
and a lot of times, that's somebody
that did what you did before,
and they understand it.
So, as a startup, look for investors
that are most likely to invest in you.
Don't be ideological about where
the money's coming from.
As long as you're getting
the money, you know.
(audience laughs)
Make sense?
- Okay, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- All right.
(audience laughs)
Our last question comes from Ben Arthur.
Is Ben Arthur in the building?
There he is.
- Hi, Gary.
- What up, Ben?
- Good, I'm a fan, man.
- I'm a fan, too, Ben.
(audience laughs)
- So, I'm gonna ask, what is the best
financial decision that have made you
and shape you today?
- (sighs) The best financial
decision I ever made
was never spending more money than I had.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
Go figure.
And what I mean by that, Ben,
and I appreciate the reaction
because that means it's
a very smart crowd.
I am fascinated that people buy things
that they can't afford
to impress people they don't like.
(audience laughs)
- Right, thanks man.
- Yeah, man, like from
a practical standpoint,
right, back to your question.
I think being aggressive's important.
When I met Mark Zuckerberg for a drink,
many years ago, it took me two seconds,
and I mean two seconds,
and I knew he was gonna win.
And so, when I went home,
and had an opportunity a year later
to buy stock from his parents, right?
I took 90% of the money that I had
saved in the bank, and
I invested it, right?
And that was a great
decision, obviously, for me.
But I didn't take 200%.
I didn't go borrow money,
things of that nature.
I took a risk, but it was
a risk I could afford.
Here's why.
If I was wrong, and it went to zero,
all that would have meant was
I couldn't eat as fancy or maybe go
as fancy on a vacation,
but it didn't mean I was
going out of business.
And too many people here take big risks
that they can't afford without thinking
about what happens when you go to zero.
I'm very aggressive, and I do a lot,
but I never take myself below zero.
I'm willing to go to zero
because I'm not fancy.
I don't need stuff.
But I'm never willing to go below zero.
Keep that in mind.
- Thanks, man.
(audience applauds)
- We have time for one more question.
- Yeah.
- So this is open to everyone.
If you have a question,
raise your hand up.
(audience member shouts)
(audience laughs)
- Who's got the mic?
- It's your (laughs)
- Yeah, okay, that crazy fucker.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
(Gary laughs)
- He's all hyped.
(audience member stammers)
(laughing)
- What's your name?
Let's start with that.
(audience member stammers)
(audience laughs)
- I have two question.
You are my idol since I was in college
back in when I was in school
at University of (speaks rapidly) of Law,
and I really want to take
photo with you, may I?
(audience laughs)
May I please?
- What'd he say?
I didn't hear, I didn't hear.
I couldn't hear it.
- You wanna say it one more time?
- May I take photo with you?
- Oh, photo, yeah.
(audience laughs)
Let's go.
(audience applauds and cheers)
(muffled speech)
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers)
- [Man] (muffled speech) facing the crowd.
(kisses)
(audience laughs)
(Gary's speech muffled)
- You're welcome, my friend.
You're welcome.
- Everybody, give your
- Jakarta.
- Give a round of applause for Gary Vee.
(audience applauds)
- I love you.
Listen, go do it.
Please, don't let this energy go away.
One fucking life, live it, please live it.
Go work, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Man] I would like to invite
Mr. Ah-kah-la Bee-ah-sah
to come up on stage for a photo session.
- [Man] Thank you.
(audience applauds)
(muffled speech)